[Musique]
clap de fin pour la centrale nucléaire
de fessenheim le 29 juin dernier
l'arrêt programmé du second réacteur
terminer une histoire industrielle
longue de 43 années si la phase de
démantèlement qui va commencer va
s'étaler sur plusieurs dizaines d'années
la fin de l'exploitation représente un
coup dur pour le territoire entre les
salariés d'edf des sous traitants l
ensemble des emplois induits
les élus locaux craignent de voir
disparaître près de 5000 emplois il s'en
inquiéter déjà cet hiver lors de l'arrêt
du premier réacteur quand bien même en
projet deux technocentre émergent
on va avoir un trou d'air de 10 ans donc
pendant dix ans comment est-ce qu'on va
occuper une partie des salariés qui
veulent pas se déplacer sur d'autres
sites qui veulent rester sur ce
territoire là ils seront forcément sur
le marché du travail
donc on va perdre aussi des compétences
qui auraient pu être utiles dans la
continuité de la filière
nucléaire mais celle du démantèlement
c'est une mort annoncée que le giro san
ça arrive c'est quand même c'est triste
et je suis vraiment très triste pour
l'ensemble des collaborateurs parce que
ça fait quelques années qu'on travaille
et que c'est une entreprise qui
fonctionne et qui fonctionnait bien
qu'ils aient encore une durée de vie
âmes ans qu'on sacrifie sur l'autel nos
telle politique qu on a du mal à
comprendre ici au niveau du territoire
les collectivités s'inquiète d'un effet
de ciseau augmentation du chômage d'un
côté et effondrement des recettes
fiscales de l'autre les pertes sont
estimées à 14 millions d'euros
autant d'argent qui fera défaut pour
accompagner le territoire de fessenheim
dans sa reconversion
la décision a été prise par l'état de
manière unilatérale il faut bien le dire
nous demandons donc à l'état d'être à
nos côtés pour la suite et nous sommes
exigeants à ce sujet auprès de l'état
qu'est ce que nous demandons à l'état
c'est d'être à nos côtés pour compenser
les pertes fiscales énorme support le
territoire et nous demandons à l'état
nous exigeons de litas d'être à nos
côtés pour nous accompagner pour
l'avenir de ce territoire en accordant
des aides financières ou en fléchant
clairement des entreprises sur le
territoire de fessenheim signé en
février 2019 un contrat de territoire
doit préparer l'avenir économique de
fessenheim au programme 700 millions
d'euros d'investissements publics et
privés pour développer les énergies
renouvelables et l'aménagement d'une
zone d'activité en février
elisabeth bornes ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire ainsi
qu emmanuelle wargon secrète à l'état
était en alsace pour préparer la période
de transition
il y a beaucoup de bonne volonté mais à
un moment donné il s'agit de concrétiser
et les devoirs des entreprises
implantées
notre problème c'est que c'est
aujourd'hui que nous perdons les emplois
à fessenheim nous ne pouvons pas
attendre dix ans pour les créer c'est
maintenant tout de suite que nous devons
le grès située sur le rhin l'avenir de
la centrale intéresse aussi
gouvernement allemand si berlin a
régulièrement demandé la fermeture du
site
aujourd'hui sur la rive orientale du
fleuve on souhaite prendre une part
active dans la construction de la praye
eux
certes les allemands demandaient la
fermeture de cette centrale
mais certes aussi les allemands sont
vraiment à nos côtés et toute une
dynamique qu'est créée dans le cadre
franco allemand pour réussir l'avenir de
ce territoire de fessenheim nous avons
des contacts j'ai envie de dire sans
arrêt après il faut que ces contacts
aboutissent aussi mais nous avons des
partenaires et français des partenaires
allemands
l'objectif c'est vraiment de faire de ce
territoire le symbole européen de la
reconversion industrielle et écologique
le territoire de fessenheim pourrait
bénéficier de sa situation frontalière
ces entreprises allemands ne cherche
désespérément de l'espace pour
s'installer
quitte à franchir le rhin concrètement
nous travaillons d'arrache-pied à la
création d'une société d'économie mixte
franco allemande pour l'aménagement de
ces terrains autour de fessenheim un
dossier qui avance et qui est un projet
phare dans le cadre de ce processus du
futur de fessenheim c'est la liaison
ferroviaire entre colmar et freiburg
parce que pour implanter des entreprises
il faut aussi de la mobilité et en
l'occurrence cette ligne ferroviaire qui
passe au nord du territoire de
fessenheim est bien va être un atout
pour faire venir des entreprises et donc
attirer des salariés
tous s'accordent à dire que fessenheim
doit conserver sa vocation industrielle
après quatre décennies d'exploitation du
nucléaire le territoire pourrait se
tourner vers les énergies renouvelables
le projet sur lequel nous travaillons
actuellement avec tous les partenaires
c'est un projet de parc du futur qui
allie à la fois de la recherche mais
aussi des industries dans le domaine des
énergies nouvelles parce que l'objectif
que nous nous sommes fixés dès le départ
ici pour le département du haut rhin
c'est de faire de fessenheim et de
l'ensemble du territoire du haut rhin
le premier territoire uniquement
alimenté en énergie positive et
décarbonée c'est un objectif certes
ambitieux mais il faut un objectif
ambitieux dans le domaine des énergies
renouvelables le département du
haut-rhin dispose déjà d'atouts sérieux
des barrages sur le rhin la plus grande
centrale photovoltaïque d'alsace et des
entreprises innovantes dans le domaine
l'horizon que je me suis donné est un
objectif ambitieux c'est d'ici dix ans
d'ici dix ans que le rein soit
uniquement alimenté en énergie positive
et décarbonées ambitieux certes mais
tout à fait réalisable alors que le
démantèlement s'amorce dans le haut rhin
les élus s'inquiètent de ne pas voir
l'état au rendez vous tous espèrent que
la crise économique consécutive à
l'épidémie de coronavirus ne fera pas
oublier au gouvernement ses engagements
pour le territoire de fessenheim